on va faire le point sur la suite des
choses mettant avec Raphaël Jacob
chercherait aussi à l'Observatoire sur
les États-Unis de la charrette
d'endurance à Raphaël alors bon ben
quelques jours plus tard on commence à
voir vraiment comment lui il arrive à
récupérer monsieur Trump cette situation
pour la jouer à son avantage finalement
absolument c'est ce qu'il a fait mardi
toute la journée c'est ce qu'il continue
lui et ses alliés à faire et il faut le
dire d'emblée Julie ça fonctionne
politiquement ça fonctionne vous savez
on se parle très souvent de sondage
d'intention de vote les sondages sont
composés de statistiques et ces
statistiques là évidemment sont faites
de répondant individuels ce sont des
êtres humains je le mentionne parce
qu'il y a une réponse d'ailleurs on voit
les résultats d'un sondage qui était
mené dans la foulée d'incubation ça
mérite d'être dit là la quasi-totalité
des réponses ont été obtenues après
qu'on a appris que dans le champ allait
être ou dans certains cas là avait été
inculpé et regardez l'avance dans une
jouer par rapport à Monsieur de Santa
c'est 30 points de marge il y a six mois
les deux étaient dépendants des sondages
là essentiellement exéco à égalité et en
énorme partie où Monsieur Trump c'est
vraiment envolé dans les intentions de
vote ça a été lorsqu'il était inculpé la
première fois à New York un peu plus de
deux mois donc il la récupérera son
avantage la première fois il est en
train de faire exactement la même chose
la deuxième fois bref je vais faire la
parenthèse pour mentionner ceci pour
vous citer en fait une réponse une
électrique républicaine du Michigan qui
a déclaré cette semaine et en ce qui me
concerne Julie c'est non seulement la
citation de la semaine c'est la citation
qui explique la dynamique politique on a
présentement au sein du parti
républicain donc je la cite mot pour mot
si ça n'avait pas été de la chasse aux
sorcières et qu'il l'avait laissé
tranquille on parle ici évidemment
Donald Trump je serai probablement pour
rendre des sentis mais puisque il
persécute mon Président je lui jure mon
allégeance fin de la citation c'est
exactement ça qu'on a comme dynamique
c'est-à-dire un ralliement un effet de
ralliement tribal derrière le leader de
la tribu en l'occurrence évidemment
l'ex-président Trump et ça met donc tous
ces rivaux à l'investisseur républicaine
dans une extrêmement embarrassante une
en fait c'est une dynamique qui est
intenable qui est impossible et ça aussi
Julie c'était exactement la même chose
qu'on avait l'art de la première
inculpation c'est-à-dire que d'abord
avant tout dans le champ commence à
prendre ou recommencer à prendre presque
la totalité de l'espace public et
médiatique donc déjà en partant ça
coincé ces adversaires et lorsque ces
adversaires essaient de sortir
publiquement à peu près les seules
questions qu'on leur posait c'était de
savoir ce qu'il pensait comment il se
positionnait par rapport donc chambre
donc c'était la diamètre qu'on avait
observé il y a deux mois deux mois et
demi dans l'État de New York c'est
exactement ce qu'on est en train de
revoir cette semaine regardez par
exemple encore une fois le rival
principal de Monsieur Trump au sein du
parti républicain monsieur De Santis
l'assuce de corde raide sur laquelle il
est placé d'un côté évidemment il peut
prendre ses distances de Monsieur Trump
c'est son rival en même temps parce que
l'écrasant de majorité de la base
républicaine demeure loyale à
l'ex-président monsieur de saint-espress
c'est un petit peu contraint de dire que
si lui-même était élu probablement qu'il
grandirait dans notre chambre quelle
situation
encore une fois impossible à tenir
politiquement donc tout ce qui se
produit même si sur le fond ça semble
être nettement plus grave que la cause
dans l'intonore que tout ce qu'on
pourrait surnommer la gastronomie
d'agence politiquement la dynamique
Julie est presque exactement la même et
elle sert à politiquement encore une
fois Monsieur Trump beaucoup plus que
celui au sein de son parti tout au moins
bon j'aimerais qu'on vienne sur un
événement qui a été très étonnant que
c'est passé en ondes sur une télé
américaine Fox News le soir justement de
sa comparution alors il était en pleine
discours de ralliement et il y a eu une
bande qui est apparue alors on voit
parce qu'on a mis en même temps des
images du président Biden donc on avait
le président actuel et l'ancien
président de rivaux évidemment
actuellement avec cette phrase apparue à
l'écran où on faisait référence à un
dictateur en herbe prend la parole à la
Maison Blanche après avoir fait arrêter
son rival politique mais là on parle de
Joe Biden ça c'est pas une citation
c'est une phrase que
Fox News écrit un rédacteur qui a écrit
ça il y a quelqu'un qui qu'est-ce que
vous comprenez de ça vous en fait je
précise d'abord avant toute le
producteur qui aurait été responsable de
l'espèce de titre a été essentiellement
démissionné on va dire comme ça là
finalement c'est pas un congédiment mais
disons que ça ressemble à ça donc pour
la forme officiellement il y a ça que
c'est produit en même temps écoutez sur
le fond et quelque chose de beaucoup
plus grave et beaucoup plus large que
simplement cette petite lettre c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est très
pertinent qu'on en parle ensemble c'est
pas simplement une bande à l'écran d'une
chaîne un soir à la télé américaine
c'est un problème qui est beaucoup plus
large que ça c'est à dire que ça ça
traduit je crois très justement et en
aucun cas évidemment ce que j'excuse
qu'on est présenté ça parce que
évidemment d'un point de vue de
nouvelles informations c'est
profondément irresponsable pour pas dire
mensonger mais ça reflète très bien la
perspective qu'à une majorité des
lecteurs républicains présentement
c'est-à-dire que de l'autre côté et je
pense très largement peut-être de notre
côté de la frontière on voit évidemment
dans notre chambre comme étant la menace
principale pour vous dire sing
pas les républicains également autrement
dit de part et d'autre on voit la
démocratie comme étant fondamentalement
menacé par l'autre partie mais
évidemment pour des raisons qui sont
diamétralement opposées et profondément
irré-conilables et ça d'un point de vue
social ou s'il y a quelque chose de
profondément grave et à la main c'est
que c'est pratiquement garanti de
monnaie une situation en fait dans
laquelle on est déjà depuis les
dernières années c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on a une élection surtout c'est
les séries ça devient de plus en plus
difficile pour le parti qui perd pour le
côté qui perd d'accepter la défaite
parce qu'il voit l'autre côté non
seulement comme un parti adverse mais
comme une menace à la démocratie comme
un ennemi carrément au pays c'est un
petit peu le climat poudrière qu'on a
présentement et évidemment qui est
alimenté particulièrement par Monsieur
Trump présentement ce serait donc le mot
de la fin à cette analyse fort
intéressante merci beaucoup Raphaël
Jacob merci